Now,
you know,
it's a truism and probably an
oversimplified one that since the dawn
of the scientific revolution,
a wedge has been driven through the
heart of our society such that the moral
systems that we use to Unitus,
so those would be religious systems
fundamentally have been subject to an
intense critique from the scientists and
you know,
it's a pretty effective critique even if
you have,
even if you've maintained a traditional
faith,
it's like
you know,
the scientific onslaught is no joke and
that's a problem as far as I can tell
because and the problem is that you're
still left with the problem of how you
should act.
And Nietzsche,
the philosopher Nietzsche,
he would say that we're running on the
fumes of Christianity in the West
because over it's thousand years of
domination to let's say,
1500 years of absolute domination.
It produced a consensus of morality that
was predicated on metaphysical
presuppositions and that organized
societies and those societies are
predicated on certain beliefs like the
belief.
And really I would say that something
divined inhabits each individual.
You know,
that's sort of presumption that's
embedded in law.
It's sort of the idea that underlies the
idea of natural,
right?
Right.
There's something about you that's so
valuable that even the law has to bow to
it.
Even if you're reprehensible,
even if you're convicted and
reprehensible now that's man,
the idea that people came up with that
idea.
That's a bloody miracle.
It's because generally speaking,
your proclivity is if someone's been
even accused of doing something,
that general human proclivity is that
even if someone's just being accused of
doing something terrible,
that's enough so that you can stone them
to death or do whatever you're going to
do with them.
Presumption of innocence before guilt,
good God,
of all the things that aren't automatic,
that's got to top the list.
You know,
it's.
It's unbelievable that that occurs,
and it's interesting to me because it
seems to me that
that presupposition that there's
something valuable transcendent about
each individual.
I wouldn't call that a scientific
presupposition,
but it seems to be a highly functional
right?
I think in that it isn't unreasonable to
notice that societies that have
value the individual and made the law
subject to the individual even with
regards to voting because that's
basically what voting does,
put sovereignty in the hands of the
people.
Those societies actually seemed to work.
Now whether they'll work for the next
300 years.
Who the hell knows?
I don't know them,
but they've worked pretty well for the
last 500 years let's say,
and we've got it pretty good right now
and you know,
I suspect most of you are rather pleased
that the law recognizes your value as
individuals and you take that for
granted,
right?
You think you have rights and of course
the rights that you have.
Natural rights are a logical consequence
of your transcendent value and that's
nested in this niche niches observation
that's nested in a set of metaphysical
beliefs.
And his idea was that if you wipe out,
sorry,
you wipe out the metaphysical beliefs
eventually wipe out the whole system
because you've knocked out the
cornerstone and it might take a long
time for the thing to shake and fall.
But,
but it will now whether he was right or
not,
it's hard to say.
It looks to me like what's happened
since Nietzsche announced the death of
God and say the late 18 hundreds is that
western society is oscillated between
extremes,
extremes on the right Germany,
extremes on the left,
and you know,
with,
with the democracies,
at least the other democracies,
democracies managing to stay the course
somewhere down the middle.
But,
but it's not obvious to me that that can
be maintained without the underlying
metaphysics.
And that's a problem because whatever
you might say about the underlying
metaphysics,
it's not true the way science is true.
And that could be okay because there
might be more than one form of truth.
In fact,
I think there is a.
I think there's pragmatic truth and I
think pragmatic truth is actually deeper
than scientific truth.
And pragmatic truth is the truth that
enable you to act in a manner that best.
It improves the probability roughly
speaking of your existence and your
reproduction maximally.
That's a Darwinian idea.
And one of the things about the
Darwinian theory just kind of puts it in
opposition to scientific materialism,
I would say,
is that the Darwinian theory is that you
don't have privileged knowledge of the
world and you can actually tell that
because you die,
right?
If you knew enough about the world,
you wouldn't die and you do die,
and so you're an embodied theory of
sorts,
and that theory is good enough to get
you along about 80 years and produced
some reasonable probability that you'll
have children and that they all survive.
That's it,
man.
That's what you've managed after 3
billion years of evolution.
It's a good enough,
it's a good enough way of acting and we
don't know a better way of acting and
our world conceptions are actually
nested inside the Darwinian system and
they might be predicated on pragmatic
truths rather than objective truths.
Pragmatic truths are truths that have
functional utility and we're alive.
We care about being alive.
We can to use our theories as tools.
It's possible that our theories are
tools and that they're tools to help us
stay alive.
Now I was reading a bit about Camille
Paglia the other day and uh,
I've noticed some similarities between,
she's a famous gadfly,
I would say a feminists have classic
modern feminists,
although she would regard yourself as a
feminist,
unbelievably smart.
Like if you want to watch someone who's
verbally who has verbal mastery beyond
belief,
it's,
you could watch Camille Paglia.
She's,
she's,
she seems a little manic to me.
She can wrap off and argument at a rate
that's just mind boggling and it's a
very coherent and she tends to shred her
opponents and arguments.
He's so brilliant.
Um,
she said something interesting and she's
been influenced by some of the same
people that I've been influenced by it.
She liked this book by Eric Norman
called the origins and history of
consciousness,
which I would recommend if you're
interested in young Ian theory,
Carl Young.
It's a good introduction to union theory
and it's about the development of
consciousness and it's predicated like
young's work and Joseph Campbell's work
and Murcia Elliot is work,
all of which has been criticized or
ignored by the postmodernist,
predicated on id on the idea that human
beings have a central narrative
and that
that central narrative is
the
dramatic expression of the necessary
human system of values and that that's
built into us.
It's,
it's,
it's part of our nature.
We have a nature as human beings.
We're not infinitely malleable white
culture,
which is a postmodernist claim and a
dangerous one.
It's dangerous if we have a nature.
Okay.
Paglia has this idea
that
the reason that you come to university
and you studied the humanities or the
proper reason if you do that,
is not to engage in premature and
destructive criticism of something that
you don't even yet understand,
but to learn as much as you can about
art and literature and poetry and drama
and fiction and religious thinking and
this is all a kind of a.
You think about it as a.
What is that?
What is all that?
It's art culture.
Music belongs in that category and like
what the hell?
What,
what about music?
It's like everyone loves it or almost
every one.
It's a mystery.
You listened to music and it's very
meaningful.
I mean music gets people through some
pretty dark times.
Why it's not obvious,
that's for sure.
You know when in most cultures,
music plays a very central role in
identity formation and you guys,
I think you'll probably find as you age
that your favorite music will be the
music that you listened to between the
ages of 16 and 20.
It's kind of like an imprint on you and
it defines a maybe that defines a
generation and maybe you know,
in our tribal past,
and this is highly likely when you were
being inculcated into the tribal culture
that was inculcated with dance and with
masks and with music all at the same
time.
So you're invited to participate in this
drama and to take your place in this
drama and to think of that as a
representation of the objective world is
just not right.
That isn't what it is.
It's an invitation to a drama.
Now.
Then the question might be,
well is the drama reel,
and the answer to that is depends on
what you mean by real.
I think that great dramas are more real
than real.
They're hyper real there.
They're hyper real because they provide
guidelines about how to act that are
abstract and even perhaps generic,
but applicable across an extraordinary
broad range of situations.